[Music]
one of my favorite things to watch of
all time
people in pain people in pain
uh we're watching today angry people at
airports
i've been going down the rabbit hole and
it's absolutely beautiful
i love it i love it so much we have this
man
uh who uh misses flight because he was
late
and he wants a refund let's watch in the
terminal it's showdown time
allen derbyshire the airport duty
manager he's checking him out he's like
i could take this guy out
he may be taller than me but look at
this [ __ ] he's ain't got muscle in his
body
at the airport has been called in to
deal with mr antaki
who's refusing to accept he can't have
an immediate refund
this is what i do not like well i'm
sorry you take the money immediately no
but you can't give it back you
arrived for the 7 30 flight too late
and that's the bottom line if you had
arrived before seven o'clock
at the check-in desk you would have now
been on the 7 30 flight no no
you obviously i it's i i feel a bit
conflicted about this i know it hasn't
started yet but
yeah these these giant companies are so
quick to take your money but then you
want to refund i
you got to wait two at least two or
three weeks bro sorry
sheesh but then again he clearly just
missed the flight
so it's like but then again
on the other side it's like yeah
sometimes the flights are late oh big
deal huh tough
just deal with it when i book a flight i
expect to go on that time
i don't care whether you you you
postpone it to earlier
later i expect i like how we added the
third one in there
uh earlier later
[Laughter]
or i expect uh i i listed too many
reasons why you're wrong
because i know i don't stay home right i
gave my mobile number
because i know i have my mobile number
with me 24
hour the bottom line he has his phone
he's on his phone 24 hours we got this
just call him
that is it you have turned up too late
oh we got some eye rolling
we can do for you i want my money you're
gonna have to write to customer service
why should i write two customers
i didn't have to write to youtube on
time so you didn't i didn't have to
write to you to pay for it if you'd have
been in here and why didn't you buy it
right
i didn't have to write to you to pay for
it finished right did that happen
that's it
did i write to you to pay for it push to
the limits allen loses his patience
your fault i don't want to go no more
fine so you've got to write to yourself
i can't why should i write to for my own
money
is what your money would you is it your
money why do you have
whip size as well all right unless you
won how much was the plane tickets
here you go what is he expecting to do i
don't understand this like i
100 agree with how frustrating it is to
deal with airlines
but at the same time just yelling at a
random employee
it's not going to fix the problem
24 hour why do i have to write
just call the police call the cops call
the cops
escort this man out and get his nokia mr
taki admits defeat mission failed
we'll get him next time maybe try
yelling more next time
i'm tired the flight was late
we waited one hour later what they had
to wait an
hour a whole hour
i'll play the saddest tambourine for you
it's cheap yes but come on sorry about
this
johnny bastian and philippa dellaree are
over from geneva on holiday
but their baby's push chair has been
broken in transit until leo finds a
solution they're going nowhere
if you want me to be realistic i can be
really really realistic you know
i can come on the other side and i'll
break your computer you'll see it
break computer that will fix it yeah
you're
threatening deliberate damage it was an
excellent damage i'm here for one week
and i have a push here i've spoken you
think i'm going to carry my baby
all around for one one week or you're
going to come with me and you carry my
baby
no you mean unreal yes yes i win all
right deal you got yourself a deal
all right if you stop yelling i'll carry
your [ __ ]
baby no one wants to carry that baby not
even in the mom look at that
i'm nervous i actually understand his
frustration now i'm sorry
i'm pregnant actually yeah so what i do
now i go crazy and then you hold
security to get me out
that's a good one i wish i could whip
out that card i'm pregnant
sorry you were late for your flight uh
we can't issue i'm pregnant
actually yeah my apologies sir here let
me give you an instant refund
leave him here you can carry him for us
no yes carry the baby
start processing your plane processing
we need to push
it carry the baby it's a baby he's one
year old he's not going to work
wait no that's the beta teach the baby
to walk
come on i mean no no i'm being realistic
now
she's being around i'm pregnant okay
i'll speak to you in five minutes
how many more times do you think she's
gonna say hey she's pregnant five
minutes we're standing here
i'm
[Laughter]
personal things like that we don't just
throw away
i said i will speak to you in five
minutes and at luton
johnny and philippa still aren't happy
you're a grown man you're tired also
sometimes he's a child
if you can you tired you grow men
he tired child uh pregnant uh break
uh pregnant a child talk to you over
here
[Music]
you need to open it you can't even open
it
it's finished it's done joe you don't
get it pigs
okay my only recommendation is and i've
put comments in the book and we've
there's some places nearby that are
still open where you can purchase
a push chair do you have the cash for
that i don't i don't have the facility
here to be able to
[Applause]
this is the only one that we've got i
don't know if that's going to be of any
use to you
uh does it go back for himself i don't
know
just take it holy [ __ ] he actually got
one are you serious
see i kind of hate this because they
clearly got their way by just yelling
managed to find them a push chair that
was suitable for them to use in our lost
baggage department that was left
unclaimed
from about two months ago so brought it
round here i didn't know what to expect
see that's well done you need to sit
down he said child he's tired the child
giggling laughing
oh man okay passengers traveling to
barcelona there are no more seats until
the 1st of january
[Music]
we don't care we have to be in barcelona
and you let me know whether you'll be
refunding the transfers the other end
and the hotel i can't wait why can't you
say that because
we've got a market here we don't have
that information to forget don't have it
someone's got it no there's a complaint
procedure in place what's recommended
we want to get the barcelona
deliberately
before tomorrow i can't why not because
there are no more services there's no
seats
why not there's no seats why not there's
no more why not
it's not an answer it's not good enough
mate it's not good enough
why not why not
i mean honestly yeah why why isn't that
i am so confused please
sorry i was walking tomorrow all right
we have a man with different approach
please it's for me the seat
i have to eat
three different approaches here i like
that i have to i just
i just have to please
why not send agreement with you
screaming yes
no you're not you're just saying my word
is my bones passing the information
yeah what information you've got nothing
i've got an agreement with you
and you've broken it he's shaking the
paper what's good about it it's not
going to help the situation
sorry i can't i can't pull planes what's
the point of you sitting here and doing
nothing
i'm trying to transfer people does
anybody want to be transferred for the
first of january lots of seats well
that's a lot
good after no years even it you stupid
three hours earlier leading the revolt
is stephen williams
right there mate you hit the nail on the
carpet
took the words out of my mouth that guy
was late for his monster gang meeting
i don't think if you're a mobster you'll
be flying easy jet to be friend
i've got sleep mate okay okay
all right would you like to cuddle up
with me we can
hit the reclaimed bug unclaimed luggage
area and you know
spread out what are you saying man i
can't do anything here for you because
i've got nothing that i can do what a
big
baby look at him
oh god i've got to sleep
what are you going what was the point
coming down here okay
oh like you're a waste of time when you
look at the so-called standards of what
easyjet
so they claim to have it is appalling
had the awesome ego correct
along with most of the barcelona
passengers opts to transfer to the next
day's madrid flight
she it's funny how people who book cheap
flights and low-cost air
lines like easyjet first class service
it's the same
with every airline though come on every
day at luton over 100 passengers missed
their flights
some take it well sorry that's a no
and some don't really oh yes
yes
[Laughter]
oh my god this is funny
oh calm down calm down
michelle sanninger has arrived 15
minutes late for the morning flight to
barcelona
i'm interviewing a whole load of
teachers what are they on the list
at a college and then i'm going to a
university to interview teachers as well
oh the teacher i let them down last time
because i think because of the september
11th they're all set up for me to see
them and i let them down at the last
minute and i you know i can't let these
guys down
all right i get it i get it it's
frustrating it's overwhelming
but jesus christ calm down please don't
do this to me
don't show up late this is why i leave
the house 14 years before my
life this is a perfect example of you
know
everyone they said 100 passengers mr
flight right
but one person had this reaction and it
just shows that you are in control of
your actions and how you respond to bad
things it happens to everyone
but how you react to it is a choice and
this is just ridiculous
you look
[Music]
michelle's pleading wins her one last
chance
really okay thank you bye-bye oh i hate
this definitely
yeah yeah yeah but she's out of luck
yeah next time he's at five plus one
that's so good gotta be moving forward
the next barcelona flight won't even
leave until after michelle should have
arrived
it's not one of her better mornings
supervisor sam jones
offers an alternative what we can do is
we can offer you it's not what you need
but it's what we can offer because it's
all we've got to offer you
and it's a free transfer so you're not
going to get charged anything else
for the lunchtime flight we'll get you
on that flight okay and then in the
meantime that gives you
time um there isn't anyone from here
we can get some numbers
well done trying to sort it out for free
as well geez
and after a four four-hour wait michelle
checks in for the barcelona
what the [ __ ] she's totally over this
flight
i'm joking the gate number is one a oh
now i feel bad maybe she's like not
mentally
right or something what the f i miss the
flag
oh god craig white is attempting to
travel from zurich to inverness
on a ticket booked under his brother
david's name
now easyjet are charging him a name
transfer fee and a surcharge of 90
pounds
damn 90 pounds just to change your name
come on this happened to me when i flew
to marta the first time actually i
i misspelled my last name by mistake
with like two letters
uh and i had to pay 50 pounds
i can't take the man but he booked his
brother's name
it's like a different person you can say
who's paying for it you can say who's
traveling
it is booked in another name and you
won't have to yeah but don't know the
name and you're watching 90 quid out
with me just to go from here to
inverness
craig's managed to get as far as lewton
i mean 90 quid that's ridiculous
this is just depressing to look at
people not able to
behave themselves in public it's just
embarrassing
this is why planes should have ejector
seats so the flight had to turn
back wow no one else go
nowhere else go
if no one goes then there will be no
airplane come on guys let's do this no
one else
can you tell me what the technical fault
is my husband's an engineer
can you tell me what the fault is my
husband is engineer so
he i can call him and then like he can
tell me
and i can just maybe like fix some stuff
together with a plane
my husband's an engineer did i mention
that
we're going to fill out the forms that
we do for
bags on arriving yeah wait so they lost
all their luggage this is absolutely
ludicrous absolutely ludicrous
you shouldn't have taken off the bikes
you should have waited
you knew yeah you should have thought of
that even though you were
here and you had nothing to do with it
you should have thought of that one huh
dumbass my husband's an engineer don't
you understand
i can list at least five engineers
oh that's so annoying
what kind of dumbass put your keys in
the chicken luggage
god damn it god damn it this is why
flying takes a it's a whole skill in its
own because you it had so much
to go through in a way i sympathize with
these people but in a way
i laugh and it gives me great pleasure
to enjoy them
watching them in pain thank you for
watching this episode if you enjoyed as
well
hit that like button subscribe right now
and i'll see you guys tomorrow
[Music]
ah